jean luc mélenchon est l'invité de
preuve par trois bonsoir bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes très
présent en ce moment auprès des salariés
confrontés à des plans sociaux mais trop
éloignés et même en rupture avec les
valeurs d'union traditionnels de la
gauche déplore le ps au pouvoir qui ces
derniers jours a ciblé ses attaques
contre vous et on dira peut-être que
c'est de bonne guerre jean luc mélenchon
après vos sévères critiques contre les
mesures prises par le duo hollande héros
que vous jugez néolibéral en tous les
cas pour certaines d'entre elles
coprésident du parti de gauche vous
répondrai dans un instant à katell
prigent de l' agence france-presse
notre partenaire et puis à perrine
tarneaud de public sénat vous l'homme de
l'année l'homme politique de l'année 1
selon le magazine jq on n'attend pas
forcément à vous lire mais en tous les
cas vous nous accordez une longue
interview je le disais donc psa goodyear
virgin
sanofi et la liste est encore longue la
liste des plans sociaux s'allongent dans
notre pays la justice aujourd'hui a
suspendu le plan de restructuration de
plus je citroën pour manque
d'information des syndicats du personnel
ce pour vous une victoire c'est disons
une wii en point d'accueil pour les
travailleurs mais dans tous les cas que
vous venez de liste et je vois un point
commun qui n'est pas du tout compris par
le gouvernement d'abord je gêne ans le
point commun à chaque fois nous sommes
victimes de la financiarisation de
l'économie c'est à dire à chaque fois
vous avez derrière ou au premier plan un
fonds d'investissement qui liquident de
l'emploi non pas parce que l'entreprise
travaille à perte mais parce qu'elle
n'est pas assez profitable c'est-à-dire
qu'ils estiment que le taux de profit
mais pas suffisant et pour faire monter
ce taux de profit il liquide des unités
entières de production c'est vrai pour
goodyear c'est vrai pour sanofi qui est
maintenant la première capitalisation
boursière de notre crise où la famille
se renie à l'état oui alors ça c'est
autre cas pour renault lie à l'état
d'une responsabilité directe des
actionnaires de l'actionnaire et de
l'état qui devrait pouvoir avoir son mot
à dire
mais dans le cas de psa là aussi nous
avons une une volonté de reconvertir par
rapport à des objectifs financiers parce
que l'entreprise a été en profite il
faut quand même le rappeler jusqu'à une
date très récente des ventes par exemple
sans s'intéresse à l'automobile bien sûr
à la vente sont en chute libre alors
addition version réduction également là
dans les usines françaises en tous les
cas
alors michel reçurent c'est là que nous
touchons du doigt l'absurdité de ce
modèle économique car le modèle
économique c'est la politique de l'offre
un mot savant pour dire on produit en
abaissant le coût du travail
bon de manière à ce qu'ils aient le plus
de marchandises possible et on se
débrouillera par les ventes mais vous
voyez bien qu'en abaissant le coût du
travail jusqu'à sa limite que fait-on
bas où on délocalise où on met des gens
au chômage et donc après vous avez moins
de consommateurs moins d'acheteurs donc
quand vous êtes sur le modèle renault ou
sur le modèle psa qui sont ni voiture
intermédiaire pour disons la classe
moyenne 1 est bien celle classe moyenne
fait passer le changement de véhicule
après les autres charges de la famille
vu qu'elle est prise et là et par
conséquent on a un modèle économique
absurde où on veut faire baisser le prix
des marchandises pour trouver des
acquéreurs qui ont eux mêmes été mis au
chômage auparavant vous voyez que tout
ça ne tient pas debout est il logique
que trois voitures sur cinq de renault
qui sont vendues en france soient
produites en dehors de france n'y
arrivera un moment où plus personne ne
pourra acheter une voiture renault en
france parce que ça sera trop cher
rapide michaud carlos ghosn patron de
renault il récuse de tout chantage
même si des négociations sont engagées
aujourd'hui avec les syndicats soutenant
pour plus de productivité même pour le
gel des salaires est certainement
gouvernement arnaud montebourg a suggéré
que carlos ghosn donne l'exemple en
réduisant ces fortes rémunérations
qu'est ce que vous proposez lui comme
moi je pour lui il faut je pense qu'il
faut changer le patron de renault nissan
parce que il a fait la preuve de son
inefficacité absolue d'abord ils coûtent
très cher je pense qu'on pourrait
trouver un patron qui coûte moins cher
pour des résultats au moins aussi
intéressant que les siens deuxièmement
il a laissé renault en jachère au profit
de nissan c'est que disent tous les
syndicats tous les syndicats 1 de
l'entreprise donc carlos ghosn est un
mauvais patrons et moi en tant
qu'actionnaire faut manger
et oui je pense qu'il faut trouver un
autre celui là a fait son temps il
il n'a pas réussi la mire nous en
difficulté ce serait un ouvrier un
contremaître un ingénieur qui aurait de
telles contre performance à son actif
carlos gohn l'aurait remplacé bien nous
nous devons remplacer carlos ghosn parce
que il n'est pas bon du tout comme
patron alors je le disais vous êtes dans
la rue avec les salariés est ce qu'on
peut sauver des emplois voire des
entreprises par la loi bien sûr oui bien
sûr tout dépend du diagnostic que l'on
pose sur la difficulté de ladite
entreprise quand vous prenez un exemple
comme sanofi c'est la première
capitalisation boursière pourquoi
supprime t-il des emplois posez vous la
question pourquoi parce que ils
voudraient que l'on passe de 35% de
redistribution du résultats en dividende
à 50 %
c'est tout c'est l'unique raison pour
laquelle il comprime l'emploi on les
entend dire qu'ils veulent investir plus
dans la recherche
aussi il tient ce discours mais c'est un
mensonge c'est ça le problème car la
recherche elle-même est soumise à la loi
de la finance et unité par unité entre
deux personnes qui travaillent sur deux
molécules différentes
l'entreprise mais la priorité à celle
qui sera le plus vite présent sur le
marché c'est-à-dire celle qui va le plus
vite dégagé un grand prof la loi aucun
sous quelle loi attendait aucun souci de
santé publique bien des lois nous allons
prendre un exemple
virgin vous avez un fonds
d'investissement qui est là dedans qui
lui ne se cache pas de ce qui fait il
écrit sur son site il dit nous revient
on prend le meilleur et on s'en va au
bout de cinq ans
donc là les cinq ans sont terminées il
s'en va de virgin auparavant il a pris
le meilleur c'est à dire le furet du
nord qu'ils ont revendue et quelques
autres perles de la couronne et puis ils
laissent un objet exemple auquel il n'a
donné aucune perspective d'avenir donc
vous voyez monsieur gros sûr on pourrait
par exemple ce que je peux vous dire n'a
rien d'une révolution socialiste viendra
de la révolution plusieurs citoyens oui
mais et elle est nécessaire
mais dans ce cas précis nous pourrions
dire par exemple que un actionnaire a un
pouvoir de vote liés à la durée de son
investissement ce qui se fait dans
certains pays comme le brésil c'est à
dire quelqu'un qui a investi pour cinq
ans n'a pas le même pouvoir de vote que
quelqu'un qui a investi pour dix ans
pour 15 ans car voyez-vous ce qui tue
l'industrie
c'est la pensée du court terme le ce
qu'on appelle le benchmarking
aujourd'hui dans le management la
conduite des entreprises s'est tous les
trois mois par conséquent il est
impossible d'avoir une stratégie de long
terme pour un patron donc chaque fois
qu'il ya un creux et bien on liquide
tout de suite pour pouvoir avoir un bon
résultat a présenté trois mois pourrait
changer les règles du capitalisme le
gouvernement que vous contestez jean luc
mélenchon et peser fiscalement sur sur
les plus hauts revenus sur les
capitaines d'industrie on a vu le
résultat
il a tenté en tous les cas avec la taxe
à 75 cents est ce que cette mesure que
vous préconisez par la loi c'est mesure
où ces lois contre les licenciements
boursiers n'aurait pas un effet pervers
de chasser tous les investisseurs de
france je ne crois pas d'abord
distinguons les quarts là il s'agit
d'une taxe que le gouvernement a imaginé
qu'ils étaient provisoires bricoler
monter n'importe comment c'est au point
qu'on se demande sont pas fait exprès
d'inventer quelque chose qui ne
passerait pas le cap du conseil
constitutionnel moi je n'ai jamais vous
savez le premier jour ils ont annoncé ça
j'ai dit qu'il n'y avait pas un seul
système fiscal au monde où on passe de
la dernière tranche de l'impôt 45 à la
suivante 75
donc moi je suis pour lisser sur
quatorze tranches est pas une taxe
maintenant revenons sur ce que vous
dites c'est la loi judith la loi
pourrait contrarier serveur est joué
elle ferait peur oui c'est que vous
n'êtes pas vous même un investisseur
michel grossiord parce que un
investisseur ne raisonne pas sur un coup
de presse un article winblad une
politique économique
un investisseur qui résonne sur la
profitabilité et la stabilité et la
visibilité point barre donc si vous
garantissez en revenus mettons 5 6%
c'est énorme dans l'industrie mais que
c'est du béton armé dans toutes les
circonstances et dans vous aurez des
dizaines de portefeuille dans le monde
qui diront ah bah je prends de l'action
française où je prends du titre français
parce que c'est stable et c'est du béton
la loi vous dit laurent berger le
nouveau leader de la cfdt un considère
lui que la meilleure façon de lutter
contre les licenciements boursiers
c'est-à-dire non justifiés
économiquement c'est ce que vous dites
ce n'est pas la loi mais c'est l'accord
récent sur la sécurisation de l'emploi
qu'il a signés avec le patronat et deux
autres syndicats donc là où il ya deux
visions oui ce n'est pas mon avis
je ne veux pas avoir de polémique avec
la cfdt joue je vous répond franchement
d'accord mais michel grossiord je vous
répond franchement pour pas que vous
ayez l'impression que je tourne autour
du ray nous nous avons fait un choix
nous polémiquons pas avec les syndicats
donc l'accord medef pour moi c'est
l'accord medef
l'accord est au medef mais non non moi
pour moi je ne vois pas ça du tout comme
ça je vais vous dire c'est un traquenard
cet accord car c'est le gouvernement qui
a convoqué cette conférence c'est pas
les syndicats qui l'ont prévenue et du
patronat le gouvernement a dit venez
discuter de ça et si vous ne vous
accordez pas je ferai une loi il aurait
dû dire ce qui mettait dans la loi parce
que ça aurait au moins aider la partie
ouvrière à négocier dans de meilleures
conditions et à la fin donc le medef en
quelque sorte sous la pression obtient
en accord qui a un caractère dans quatre
mois serait un accord il légal même pas
quatre mois de moi pourquoi parce que la
loi accorde noah demain ah mais attendez
c'est pas fait mais déjà entendez mon
argument si nous étions au mois d'avril
la nouvelle loi sur la représentativité
s'appliquerait et la signature qui a été
donnée au medef ne voudrais rien car les
deux syndicats qui sont majoritaires
dans tous les cas une fois qu'ils sont
ensemble elles fo et la cgt ne l'ont pas
signé si vous y ajoutez sud solidaires
vous avez un front syndical extrêmement
rare qui représente plus de la majorité
des salariés dans ces conditions au mois
d'avril cet accord était directement à
la poubelle parce qu' il n'aurait pas eu
le nombre de voix suffisante pour être
valide et enfin son contenu est terrible
pour les entreprises car l'illusion
récurrents les entreprises pour les
salariés pour les entreprises
elles-mêmes parce que qu'est ce qu'une
entreprise gagne à voir son salariat
être déstabilisé vivre dans la peur du
lendemain être maltraités puisque vous
savez que cet accord prévoit que si dans
l'entreprise ou cinq ans sur le sujet on
peut réduire le salaire on peut
augmenter le temps de travail que le
vrai l'élever les mauvaises périodes
mais on peut les passer de bien des
manières par exemple perdre son emploi
centre monsieur c'est ce qu'ils disent
au début parce que chacun
non non mais il nous ce gros sur vous
seriez le premier à dire que si une
entreprise qui a passé un tel accord ne
voit pas ses comptes se redresser
puisqu'elle prétend que c'est à cause la
dégradation de ses comptes annuels voilà
qu'elles menacent ces ouvriers le
pistolet sur la tempe et elle leur dit
êtes vous d'accord pour faire un accord
compétitivité mais si la même entreprise
au bout de quelques mois de
fonctionnement n'améliore pas ses
performances qu'est-ce qui se passe
est-ce que vous avez vous monsieur
grossiord le pouvoir dans la loi d'aller
contre la propriété privée des moyens de
production qui peut décider de fermer la
boîte ou de la vendre comme ça s'est
passé chez convenait pas prévue dans
l'avenant en effet et chez conti ce
n'était pas prévu donc les travailleurs
ont augmenté leur temps de travail
réduit leur paye et au bout de deux ans
on leur a fermé la boîte
donc c'est un accord de dupes à mes yeux
et surtout monsieur grosseur puisque là
nous parlons sur la chaîne sénat où donc
on s'intéresse à la loi des
parlementaires de gauche corrige monde
ait évidemment le devoir des
parlementaires de gauche moi lorsque
j'étais sénateur j'ai toujours dit qu'un
législateur n'est pas une caisse
enregistreuse il doit discuter au nom de
la société cet arrêt cinq ans le ps c
est lui le ps avait main ce qu'il veut
il ne sera pas obéi
car en tout cas pas par nous parce que
nous présenterons des amendements
les groupes du front de gauche à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
présenteront des amendements et le débat
aura lieu et je connais beaucoup de
socialistes
et j'ajoute beaucoup d'élus europe
ecologie les verts ils ont voté sur ce
thème qui sont décidés à avoir là il va
on va voir dans un instant si vous
essayez d'installer un nouveau front
contre le gouvernement même si les
écologistes je le rappelle sont quand
même au gouvernement jean luc mélenchon
je note que marine le pen elle a déclaré
a pour ambition de prendre la tête
justement de la contestation contre cet
accord sur le marché du travail la
sécurisation de l'emploi a décidément
vous retrouvez toujours face à face
alors si elle dit elle défend la france
des invisibles elle revendique je sais
c'est un emprunt continue elle à bout
vocabulaire et tout ça mais bon elle
avance masqué madame le pen n'est pas
l'ami des travailleurs parce que je ne
vous dire une chose si elle l'était elle
commencerait par aider les syndicats
orale et anti syndicats elle les dénonce
comme une mafia pourri corrompu
heureusement que nous avons des
syndicats qui défendent les intérêts des
travailleurs et pas madame le pen par
conséquent si madame le pen a décidé
aujourd'hui des collectivistes et 2
de pousser à une loi contre
l'interdiction des licenciements
boursiers la mystique des syndicalistes
qu'elle déteste etc
on s'en plaindra pas mais je crois que
c'est pas ça qu'elle a l'intention de
faire a l'intention de duper d'enfumer
de mystifier comme l'ont fait avant dans
le passé toujours les mouvements
d'extrême droite qu'est ce que vous
voulez peuvent quand même pas venir
simplement du mal à partager même bas ou
sur le dispute seulement sa wii on se le
disputent bien sûr eux ils ont intérêt à
se donner bonne mine parmi les
travailleurs mais j'espère que les
travailleurs qui sont des citoyens comme
les autres qui réfléchissent bas vont se
rendre compte que madame le pen n'est
pas leurs amis c'est leur ennemi madame
le pen c'est l'ami des patrons alors
jean-luc mélenchon je le disais le parti
socialiste ne goûte guère vos attaques
contre une orientations néolibérales que
vous condamnez elle met la pression en
ce moment sur votre partenaire
communiste c'est l'un des aspects que
l'on va aborder avec katell prigent de
l' agence france-presse
c'est qu'ils arrivent dans un instant
mais d'abord le point donc sur sur ces
échanges entre anciens camarades de même
entre un ancien trotskiste en a je pense
avec cambadélis
on voit ça avec à dire que moi j'ai été
trop de kills trois ans et demi en temps
même différent ancienneté qui se ressent
d'ailleurs à l'oreille vous leur
répondre et dans un instant mes enfants
avec lui s'éteint un brave ami qui fait
ce qu'il peut pour reprendre le terrain
perdu
fabrice cuvée d'abord avant notre
concert de la lfp que se passe-t-il
place du colonel fabien
la question agite gouvernement et parti
socialiste
le pc allié historique joue la carte de
la rupture
une minorité représentée dans ce front
de gauche par le parti de gauche ne peut
pas éliminer face et d'un revers de la
main cette histoire commune en tous les
cas nous nous ferons tout en sorte pour
que la porte reste bien évidemment
ouverte et qu'encore une fois ce soit la
gauche mais la gauche unie qui
l'emportait pas une gauche divisée comme
est en train de le faire jean luc
mélenchon une minorité dicterait la
ligne du front de gauche pourtant ce
lundi matin
la coordination nationale parle d'une
seule voix au moment de mettre la
dernière touche au texte stratégique
un texte qui doit donner le ton des
prochaines semaines
le soin qu'elle ait débat on est neuf
parties dont on imagine bien que les
délais mais ce que je constate c'est que
les débats se sont toujours résolu
positivement au fil du temps donc voilà
ça le front gauche damien la ligne du
front de gauche est clair s'opposer à la
politique économique du gouvernement et
faire des propositions alternatives
pierre laurent le sait pour le parti
communiste
c'est quitte ou double tout est fait
pour nous enfermer vole unique qu'est ce
qu'ils ont pour contre la politique
gouvernementale
or l'urgence de la situation est bien de
faire d émerger une parole large
nombreuses si nous parvenons pas là
c'est la situation peut évoluer de
manière très défavorable
si nous y parvenons il peut se passer
des choses intéressantes le front de
gauche a un atout ces parlementaires ce
mardi matin
députés et sénateurs se retrouve à
l'assemblée nationale et pas question
d'évoquer des tensions vis-à-vis de la
ligne politique dictée par jean luc
mélenchon égard des interrogations non
mais je crois que là le front gauche
entend elle n'est n'est pas remis en
cause par les communistes il s'interroge
sur comment encore élargir ce
rassemblement à d'autres forces de
gauche c'est tout l'enjeu des
discussions commencé ce mardi entre le
parti de gauche et les verts ces
derniers ne serait pas insensible à
l'idée de constituer une majorité
alternative
alors simple pression sur le
gouvernement et le ps ou véritable
rapprochement
ils ont quelques mois avant de choisir
leur camp voilà qu'apple prigent de l'
agence france-presse
question et jean luc mélenchon alors
monsieur mélenchon ou est-ce que comme
le dit jean christophe cambadélis dans
une lettre ouverte qui vous est adressée
rien ne trouve grâce à vos yeux dans
l'action du gouvernement
non ça me déçoit parce que vous voyez
que quand on leur fait des bonnes
manières il ne les retient de même par
even manière mais oui voyez nous avons
voté le collectif budgétaire au mois de
juillet pourquoi parce qu'il revenait
sur le bouclier fiscal parce que il est
où il y avait une augmentation de
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire
bon ça ça a été fait lorsque est arrivée
la loi sur le mariage pour tous nous
étions en première ligne pour manifester
et on nous a dit mais quoi vous êtes en
train de soutenir les socialistes on a
rappelé que non puisque nous étions
l'initiative de tout ça mais mais il
sait pas un problème
donc quand il s'agit d'aller dans ce
sens là il n'y a pas de problème quand
arnaud montebourg s'est prononcé pour la
nationalisation temporaire
si j'étais le monsieur surenchère que
pointent du doigt monsieur comme
intelligent dit pourquoi temporaire il
faudrait qu'elle soit définitive non la
d'y aller on y va
prenons un autre exemple dans
l'actualité benoît hamon a sous le coude
une loi qui parait-il sera présenté au
mois de
qui prévoit que les travailleurs auront
un droit de préemption sur leur
entreprise quand leurs patrons
l'abandonnent ou qu'il veut la fermer
sans lavande en droit de préemption des
travailleurs et obligations devront être
nous soutenons je vais même vous dire
mieux pour l'émission de ce soir je
demande au gouvernement d'accélérer la
présentation de la loi en urgence de
benoît hamon
pourquoi attendre le mois de juin alors
qu'il ya des dizaines d'entreprises qui
ferment c'est maintenant on a besoin
mes camarades de piles pas que j'ai vu
tout à l'heure 10 nous voulons créer
notre notre coopérative maintenant les
travailleurs de fralib disent la même
chose
donc voilà là je ne peux pas faire mieux
c'est bien une loi d'un membre du
gouvernement
je demande que la loi amont viennent je
demande aux socialistes on pourrait
s'accorder là dessus la loi sur
l'amnistié des syndicalistes qui est
déposé ici au sénat le 27 ou 28 février
prochain on peut la voter ensemble les
espaces existe ce qui n'est pas possible
c'est qu'on nous demande d'obéir le
doigt sur la couture du pantalon
d'acclamer en cadence de se réjouir de
se féliciter vous est imprévisible avec
vos camarades communistes et çà
transforme le sénat en chambre qui n'a
plus de majorité
mais en quoi sommes-nous imprévisible
n'y a pas plus prévisible que nous c
nous sommes légion est plus simple du
monde puisque nous avons annoncé à l'as
vence avec quoi nous étions d'accord
avec quoi nous ne sommes pas d'accord
mais si on pense que la réponse à nous
faire est de nous dire c'est comme ça
sinon vous enlève au poste d'adjoint
dans les mairies ça nous traitait une
manière indigne et par conséquent les
communistes en particulier le prennent
très mal de se voir parler de cette
façon là et moi aussi
donc si vous étiez un peu mieux traités
par le ps vous seriez prêt à soutenir le
gouvernement
il jean marc ayrault mais c'est pas une
affaire personnelle c'est une affaire de
ligne politique
je vais vous donner encore un exemple
nous ne sommes pas d'accord avec la
politique néo libérale ou sociale
libérale c'est la même chose de l'offre
alors c'est un peu compliqué mais ça
veut dire nous ne sommes pas d'accord
avec le contenu donné par le président
de la république à son orientation
économique c'est à dire on doit produire
en baissant coût du travail partout et
on fait 20 milliards de cadeaux comme ça
aux entreprises au total 50 milliards
d'euros auront été retirés de l'économie
réelle de ce pays par les diminutions de
dépenses publiques et par les
augmentations d'impôts c'est quelque
chose de considérable
on n'est pas d'accord avec ce cap bon on
l'a dit on l'a expliqué on a des
arguments
mais pourquoi voudriez vous que après
avoir expliqué fait des contre
propositions de toutes sortes y compris
tout à l'heure vous ne parliez des
impôts bon ils se sont plantés avec leur
affaire de taxe exceptionnelle à 75 on
sent qu'ils tenaient pas la route
on avait proposé de faire une
augmentation brd et tranche 1 de manière
à ce que l'on 14 pour lisser l'histoire
et remplir les caisses de l'état mais
comment rendre au fait des propositions
la réponse ça peut pas être pire que les
y'a rien à voir avec l'odyssée en
cadence féliciter vous réjouissez vous
si je viens de vous le dire si la loi
amont arrive en débat là nous la
voterons si on met trois tranches quatre
tranches d'impôts de plus même si c'est
pas 14 dans l'impôt sur le revenu pour
remplacer l'ancienne taxe à 75%
nous la voterons j'en suis sûr d'accord
c'est une affaire de cohésion ce pas une
affaire personnelle moi j'ai pas de
fâcherie personnel avec les socialistes
que je connais de les fréquenter 30 ans
mais vous restez prêt à gouverner nous
l'affirmé ab oui je pense que le
meilleur ou la meilleure participation
que je puisse avoir un gouvernement
c'est de le diriger moi-même pardon ça
peut vous paraître un peu mais je vois
pas comment qui peut être mieux placés
que moi pour pour conduire cette
politique à moi ou un autre un du front
gauche alors est ce que c'est en
préparation de cette idée gouverner que
vous avez rencontré les verts ce matin
toujours à son accent tête
on ne peut pas on peut pas avoir été
candidat à une élection présidentielle
et puis dire aux gens au revoir
on se reverra dans cinq ans non on est
obligé de dire c'est maintenant c'est
tout de suite qu'on peut régler les
problèmes de quelle manière il ya la
lutte syndicale la lutte sociale
et puis nous notre rôle politique c'est
de dire nous sommes prêts à tout moment
à diriger alors comment faire
on peut pas parler avec les socialistes
puisque ils nous répondent sur le ton
que vous savez mais il ya des gens qui
sont ouverts à la discussion ça ne pas
dire sont d'accord avec nous mais europe
ecologie les verts acceptent de discuter
avec nous qui plus est le parti de
gauche est un parti écologiste donc nous
avons un terrain commun on voit pas
l'écologie tout à fait de la même
manière mais ça vous savez nous à gauche
ont toujours fort pour trouver des
différences mais on a un espace commun
c'est vrai ça facilite la discussion et
nous avons décidé de mettre en place des
ateliers de la politique écologique
concrète ce matin sur un certain nombre
de domaines on va voir jusqu'à quel
point où aller le front de gauche que ce
s'élargir jusqu aux écologistes
mais le front gauche nagel ne s'est
jamais vécue comme une fin en soi le
franco j'en écoutais morceaux vers le
front de gauche est un déclencheur c'est
un c'est un éclaireur nous avons sans
cesse à l'esprit comment on peut élargir
la surface sur laquelle nous pouvons
travailler imaginer qu'on compte
découvre qu'on est d'accord avec les
écologistes je vais prendre un sujet qui
prête pas trop à confusion je mets de
côté pour l'instant le nucléaire mais je
pourrais venir
mais par exemple qu'on se trouve
d'accord sur la politique de la mer
c'est à dire donner la maîtrise de
l'océan des océans comme un objectif
pour l'économie française comme
autrefois on a fait le train à grande
vitesse la fusée que sais-je encore qui
ont été des d'immenses succès
industriels donc là on aurait une force
de conviction extraordinaire et là nous
sommes plutôt tous d'accord depuis les
forces sociales liées au mouvement
syndical de la mer jusqu'aux
organisations politiques vous oui on
amènerait une bouffée d'air frais quoi
un peu d'espoir d'accord et vous avez
deux stratégies différentes
oui les vers et les verts acceptent de
participer au gouvernement et vous non
voilà comment est ce qu'on peut se
dépasser que d'une manière c'est que ça
change
voilà est-ce que vous estimez que les
verts n'ont plus leur place dans le
gouvernement puis soviétique comme vous
je je je je ne me risquerai jamais à ça
on sait pas de pratique politique on
n'est pas de ma dire toi pas bien toi si
toi là on part des contenus des choses
avec lesquelles on est d'accord des
choses avec lesquelles on n'est pas
d'accord
par exemple le les socialistes pensent
que nous avons que nous faisons une
fixation sur eux mais c'est pas le sujet
nous leur disons regarder d'autres
affaires a très mal tourné en espagne au
portugal en grèce
expliquez-moi pourquoi vous croyez
qu'elle va mieux tourner en france alors
que vous même vous dites disent les
socialistes dit le président de la
république qui aura trois cent mille
chômeurs de plus cette année
bon mais est ce qu'ils se rendent compte
de l'état dans lequel est déjà le pays
donc voilà ce que je veux
on peut s'accorder à tout instant à tout
instant pour des mesures qui vont de
l'avant mais qui sont des mesures de des
financiers risation de l'économie de
d'égalitarisme fiscale on peut
s'accorder à tout moment et on demande
rien en échange
on ne demande pas des postes d je ne
sais quoi rien simplement que la vie des
gens qui ont lancé un coin dans la
majorité gouvernementale la tente et ça
c'est vous qui le dites vous êtes
observateur bon moi et j'ai fait mon
travail avec mes camarades qui est
d'élargir d'essayer sans cesse de
trouver des issues positives on va pas
rester en chine de faïence comme ça
jusqu'à 2017 quand même il faut bien que
les choses bougent et puis vous nous
allons avoir bientôt une grande
direction
l'élection de 2014 20 je parle pas des
municipales dans un seul à faire du pcf
bosser plutôt faire du pcf ça nous
concerne très directement
il faut que la gauche marque des poids
dans cette élection municipale ça va
aussi créer un entre guillemets un
problème au front de gauche parce que
vous tentez le vin vous espérez le vote
sanction vis-à-vis du ps
or le paysan c'est compliqué même allié
au ps va devoir défendre un bilan dans
l'est dans les mémoires c'est plus
compliqué que ça parce que d'abord vous
savez comme moi
vous êtes ici dans le sénat donc on est
plus sensible ici on connaît mieux cette
réalité là vous prenez les communes de
moins de 3500 habitants
écoutez vous savez très bien qu'on fait
pas des scrutins de listes politiques
ont fait des listes citoyenne c'est ce
que nous on va essayer de faire des
listes le pouvoir citoyen y aura tout le
monde
bon après on passe dans d'autres
catégories les grandes villes paris lyon
marseille sont des villes très politique
donc le scrutin un tournant plus
politique c'est moins vrai dans des
communes plus petites donc on va avoir
du mal à donner en quelque sorte un
regard général nous le parti de gauche
nous sommes pour des listes autonomes
partout l'on peut mais pas d'une manière
ils responsables par principe
même quand on a un maire socialiste ou
une mairie socialiste qu un chic type
où est la même chose deux parties que
misère ne rien savoir
non c'est ça absurde de se comporter
comme ça c'est pourquoi je trouve
l'élection municipale mois significatif
politiquement mais elle sera vous le
verrez marqué par une abstention
absolument incroyable que l'élection
européenne ou là nous avons un cas
politique et le cap politique
je reviens à votre première fois c'est
le ps l'a clairement oui mais déjà le
père politique de 2014 c'est que nous
sommes contre le traité mercredi que les
socialistes ont adopté
nous ne sommes pas les seuls les
écologistes aussi sont contre par
conséquent vous voyez que dans les fêtes
il y à des convergences minutes pour
votre jean marc ayrault va également
recevoir les parlementaires écologistes
est ce que ça va devenir votre
nouveau-né terrain de jeu l'écologie
entre le ps et financé par un terrain de
jeu pour nous c'est en tout cas là je
parle pour le parti de gauche et puis
pour le front de gauche
non maintenant c'est une dimension
structurante nous on a beaucoup
travaillé sur nous mêmes parce que les
socialistes ont toujours rien compris
mais mais l'écologie politique est la
grande question du 28 le 6 avril ont
leur place dans le front de gauche dans
le front de gauche je sais pas c'est pas
comme ça que j'ai fait il ya le front de
gauche et les écologistes et on peut
avoir des alliances un coutelas depuis
un quart d'heure et katell on se dit
quand on vous écoute pour vous l'échec
du gouvernement socialiste est assurée
oui je sinon
de quoi parlera et ont bien sûr cette
politique ne peut pas marcher monsieur
gossio or mais je vous le dis clairement
elle n'a marché nulle part pourquoi est
ce qu elle marcherait ici elle ne
marchera pas c'est bien je ne mise pas
si vous voulez c'est là que la
discussion avec les socialistes est
rempli d'un cynisme inacceptable ils
disent vous misez sur l'échec n'est pas
du tout je le redoute je passe mon temps
à éviter cet échec en faisant des
propositions mais c'est absolument
certain
vous n'allez quand même pas me parler
d'une réussite quand le chef de l'état
lui même dit qu'il va y avoir trois cent
mille chômeurs de plus quand tu appelles
l'accord m'aider à sept-îles signé que
renault s'en sert comme d'un pistolet
sur la tempe des salariés de
l'entreprise tout de même alors ou alors
ils n'ont plus de sens juste un mot pour
dire la décision d'intervenir au mali
qui revient françois hollande s à
l'honneur l'honneur de la france quand
on voit ce qui se passe dans les villes
libérées
la joie de la population s'il a subi les
plus voir le jour islamistes elle est
dans mon show où la joie de la
population y viennent aussi libéré par
par par noah ringer de la france comme
se dessine mais ce sont nos grands mots
les grands mots oui j'aime les grands
mots mais dans la guerre il faut faire
attention aux mots qu'on utilise moi on
m'a demandé si j'étais pour ou contre
j'ai dit c'est discutable je peux
exposer les raisons pour lesquelles la
situation me paraît discutable
maintenant nos armes attendez nos armes
sont engagés je souhaite leur victoire
il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté sur le sujet
mais pour autant les raisons que j'ai
posée de disputer sont des raisons
fondées et d'ailleurs je vous en donne
la preuve nous sommes en train d'occuper
le nord-mali pas pour l'occuper nous les
français nous n'avons pas l'intention
d'annexer le nord-mali alors à thiais
allons-nous le remède s'il vous plaît à
votre rayonnement c'est de trouver une
solution politique cei ne trouve une
seule grille en un pouvoir légitime donc
dans les élections sont d'ailleurs
annoncés d'ici voilà la première des
choses à faire c'est d'organiser des
élections libres et honnêtes et stable
au mas cvt et ensuite de ne pas
confondre la lutte contre les islamistes
avec la lutte contre les touaregs parce
que ce n'est pas du tout pareil je sais
que tout ça paraît un peu sophistiqué
mais la guerre est plus sophistiquée
qu'elle en a l'air mais les cours ne
règle pas tous les problèmes politiques
ainsi qu'à tel perrine tarneaud donc de
public sénat arrive
juste après ces images sépia vous
concernant jean luc mélenchon ne vous
trouve pas que dans les magazines à la à
la mode toujours en vente dans les
kiosques
on voit ça avec alexandra colinot vous
êtes jaloux quoi la bascule par nous
mêmes un bijou qu'est ce que vous voulez
c'est passé de gueule la bataille
continue à bien des hauts et des bas
balaci le bakoye c'est un soir de
défaite celle des cantonales de 92 à
massy jean luc mélenchon n'a pas encore
le costume noir et la cravate rouge du
présidentiable il est élu ps et croit
encore que le parti changera les choses
vingt ans ont passé et l'homme un
patient du parti socialiste est devenu
un homme en colère
moi je le perçois comme de la colère de
voir ce qui a été quand même son
engagement un grand parti qui devait
être le parti de rénovation de la gauche
qu'apportait de très lourdes réformes en
80 et dont il a le sentiment que petit à
petit c'est tellement dévitalisées que
l'orage passe que ça paralyse la bouche
dans son dos ou pas eu de la butte
le 21 avril 2002 est un choc profond le
divorce avec le psg signé en 2008
à ceux qui comme ça je tourne la page je
vais continuer mon combat précisément
pour aller à la rencontre de ces forces
de gauche et construire une force
politique nouvelle
jean luc mélenchon se prépare alors non
pas au grand soir mais un séisme
politique celui d'où émergera une
nouvelle gouvernance
mais si le tri d'un s'est enthousiasmé
les foules par ses bons mots et ses
grands gestes
jean luc mélenchon serait plutôt un
cassandre et la fois une vision tragique
de l'histoire qui est de dire que les
choses peuvent mal mal se passait mal
tourné et en même temps qu'eux
toto l'empêcher pense que c'est lourd je
pense qu'il a une vie très spécial et ça
le met à 10 ans une forme de légèreté
d'une forme de bons de je m'en foutisme
de d'hédonisme l'homme ne semble prendre
aucune distance avec cette réalité
qu'ils regardent d'un oeil pessimiste de
l'optimisme il y en a quand même un peu
mais uniquement dans le combat voilà
perrine tarneaud nous a rejoint jean luc
mélenchon père est lourd dit françois
delapierre jean luc mélenchon bonsoir
c'est lourd
l'engagement est total et du coup la
prise de distance est impossible
j'espère quand même être capables de
prise de distance parce que j'ai une
formation philosophe et je sais bien que
on ne peut pas avoir de jugement
critique au sens de jugement fondé et
raisonner autrement qu'en mettant les
événements à distance mais c'est vrai
que je vis le l'engagement politique
comme un acte de construction de mâts de
ma propre personnalité n'a pas que pas
que moi j'ai toujours dit à mes amis
dans l'action politique on construit
plus qu'un projet on se construit soi
même dans une dimension d'altruisme
alors des fois il ya un revers à ça
comme les égoïstes on à revers
l'attitude positive d'un égoïste et qui
s'en sort le revers c'est que les autres
tours peut mourir et qu'il s'en sortira
pas de la même manière dans le sens
inverse
trop d'empathie peut parfois conduire à
une forme d'identification aux
événements qui est accessible ça arrive
enfin j'estime que c'est un moindre
inconvénient mais quand ils disent est
lourd on sent aussi de l' angoisse
olé bon ça a un côté un peu intimiste
c'est jeu je me fais à ces questions
voilà regardez moi bien je suis un petit
pied noir au départ c'est à dire que
contrairement à vous ou à vous michel
grossiord que je connais depuis très
longtemps
moi je sais que l'histoire comme mal
tourné
c'est à dire que quand on se trompe
quand on croit de toute sa force à
quelque chose qui est erronée le bilan
peut être désastreux pour la population
d'origine européenne de l'afrique du
nord
l'erreur qu'a consistait pour elle le
fait de supporter qu'une partie aussi
importante de la population soient
maltraités n'ai aucun droit
c'est une erreur ils ont supporté lors
leur manque d'altruisme leur incapacité
à vouloir l'égalité église a conduit à
leur propre perte c'est à dire à être
chassés d'un endroit qu'ils aimé
passionnément
donc moi j'ai ce sentiment tragique de
l'histoire michel grossiord lui il est
jurassien
donc personne ne met jamais important
dans notre débat mais oui c'est une
bonne illustration vous êtes un français
typique caractéristiques bon jamais à
aucun moment il vous viendrait à l'idée
que quelqu'un puisse venir vous dire
vous vous avez peut-être quatre
épaisseurs de vos anciens dans les
tombes mais vous n'êtes pas chez vous
vous comprenez et bien ce sentiment
tragique de l'histoire med a pensé qu'
il n'est pas vrai que tout s'arrangera
toujours tout seul il faut y mettre un
engagement personnel profond il faut
aimer la colère comme moteur pour cissé
que la résignation va écouter plutôt que
la résignation bien sûr à la verse il
faut aimer sa patrie
pour moi ce sont des mots qui compte est
ma patrie je mets toujours républicaine
parce que c'est l'attachement à
l'égalité qui nous unit oui bien sûr la
colère des foires remède mais comment
s'en sortir ce film en phase iib alliés
wing des fois il peut mais quel est le
sentiment humain qui n'a pas sombré à
une y en a pas vous avez été eu des fois
son très décevant
les babas aussi mêlé c'est the oc c'est
une affaire de savoir être utile et que
vous corriger est ce que vous vous êtes
corrigé vous-même depuis la
présidentielle par exemple sur certains
points ben il a surtout fallu que je
m'adapte à la nouvelle situation parce
que non mais je parle du rapport
personnel que l'on a aux autres qu'ils
aient modifié d'une manière incroyable
par une élection comme celle là bon moi
je le découvre oui vous avez un crafter
entier donc vous pouvez suscité beaucoup
d'adhésions d'empathie mais aussi
beaucoup de rejet on l'a vu
pire encore ce week-end dans le figaro
magazine il y avait un acteur gérard
lanvin qui a dit de vous que vous êtes
un surexcités notoire qui prône le
désordre
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez à rien
je vous invite à regarder plus
attentivement peut-être faire preuve de
2 - 2 tranches en moi je jamais comme le
désert ne me prends pour l'excitation
ski de l'indignation
oui je pense que si vous voulez la
tentation des gens de droite est
toujours la même à notre égard nous
sommes des animaux
nous l'avons toujours été pour eux
lorsque je regarde les caricatures des
hommes de gauche du début du 19e siècle
ils sont toujours représentées insultes
il vivra les femmes se déploient les
cheveux en blond parlons ceux de droite
sont pas forcément mieux caricature et
souvent ils les mots qui servent à nous
caractérise et sont toujours des mots
qui vise la personne moi je fais de
l'humour mais je demande je comprends qu
on n'approuve pas mes idées je le
comprends parfaitement pu d'ailleurs
heureusement c'est ça une démocratie la
force d'un peuple c'est la confrontation
des idées et par consensus un contre
comme gérard lanvin parle mais quand les
deux ont grandi surexcités qu'est ce
qu'il sème le désordre quotidienne at-il
dit l'homme du désordre c'est vrai que
vous attendez vous le dites vous même un
détail fortuite qui mènera la révolution
c'est bien ça non c'est pas ça
mais le l'homme du désordre c'est tout
de même incroyable qui est le désordre
dans ce pays sinon ceux qui organisent
la catastrophe économique industrielle
sociale à laquelle nous sommes
confrontés
non moi je suis un nom d'ordre mais d'un
autre ordre quand même une révolution
possible
alors oui mais nécessaire je suis
partisan d'une révolution citoyenne
c'est à dire que je pense que notre pays
a besoin d'une immense réconciliation
civique le nombre de gens qui dorénavant
ne croient plus à rien dénigre toutes
les institutions non confiance en aucun
homme politique aucun journaliste rend
cette société malade mais la société se
plaint beaucoup mais s'indigne peuvent
se révoltent pas beaucoup vous le savez
par madame la société s'indigne beaucoup
se révoltent beaucoup mais la vie est dû
il est difficile de faire connaître sa
révolte quand de son emploi a peut-être
menacée qu'en toute votre famille dépend
de votre paye donc les gens souvent sont
conduits à baisser le nez mais pour
autant il continue à réfléchir et à
ressentir cette forte indignation la
meilleure des preuves c'est moi comment
expliquez vous qu'un homme comme moi
puisse réunir 4 millions de voix
pourquoi pourquoi sommes nous passés du
score inférieur à 3% à un score
supérieur à 10% pour quelles raisons ça
ne tient pas à ma cravate rouge ou à mes
talents d'orateur j'ai toujours une
cravate et j'ai toujours été un oratoire
et jusqu'à combien pouvoir cela tient
cela tient à la situation qui a conduit
des tas de gens s'identifiaient remonte
discours est à dire oui il dit ce que
nous pensons et donc nous allons l'aider
les autres sont bien on l'aidera le
prochain cours qu'est-ce qui pourrait
être l'étincelle pour déclencher cette
révolution citoyenne
non que vous souhaitez alors voilà
comment les choses se passent les
révolutions ne se font jamais pour des
raisons idéologiques
le mot révolution d'ailleurs fait peur
les gens pas envie de révolution mais à
un moment donné la société ne remplit
plus les fonctions qu'on attend d'elle
l'ordre par est injuste les puissants
illégitime et sur un détail fortuit les
gens se saisisse de la situation nous
allons régler ça nous mêmes
voilà et c'est comme ça que se font les
grands mouvements de l'histoire et nous
les avons vus dans le maghreb par
exemple dans le moyen-orient les le
point de départ de la grande promotion
vient d' événement tout à fait fortuit
et ensuite ce qui m'intéresse c'est que
les gens se saisisse de la politique
et moi je suis pour inventer un système
qui articule la capacité à articuler un
grand - mais tu y arrives à marier la
capacité cette capacité de la société
s'investir dans ces affaires et des
institutions je vais vous donner un
exemple tout bête là il nous allons
avoir les élections d'équateur où je
pense que nous allons gagner haut la
main eh bien il ya un système politique
dans lequel nous vous faites partie d'un
mouvement international
oui bien sûr c'est un mouvement
international très divers dans ses
composantes mais oui c'est le même
mouvement c'est la révolution citoyenne
l'on s'appelle comme ça de même donc
bien eh bien vous il ya des institutions
parce qu'il faut des institutions je le
dis aux gens la démocratie directe
permanente ça ne salit pas gérable il
faut dans la ville et l'institution mais
il faut que les institutions restent
dans la main du peuple dont il inventait
le référendum révocatoire que ce soit au
venezuela où que ce soit en équateur et
je proposerai qu'on le fasse demain pour
la france vous pouvez avoir un
référendum révocatoire c'est à dire que
quand vous avez bon là pour eux c'est le
15 pour cent pour la présidentielle le
10 % pour un député
les gens signent ils disent nous voulons
un référendum révocatoire que nous ne
sommes pas contents de monsieur
mélenchon de monsieur grossiord bon et
nous élever mon nom puis rémy a dit
comme ça où ça peut faire frémir se
déroule à la mecque
mais c'est l'ordre ça on fait la
démocratie mais c'est la démocratie et
c'est l'ordre parce que ça veut dire que
à tout moment le citoyen a le pouvoir
mais au prix d'un effort il faut aller
voir les autres
comment et dispensant de la population
de signer un texte nouveau motif soit
percé sérieux et assez grave pour
arriver à réunir cette proportion s'est
pas beaucoup pour évoquer un bain pour
avoir un référendum pas pour rien
il ya une campagne électorale il faut
pas avoir peur du vote dans une
démocratie on peut voter souvent on dit
les gens sont fatigués de voter pas du
tout les gens sont fait qu'ils viennent
voter que ça ne serve à rien c'est pas
pareil
vous dites que votre plus grande source
de révolte depuis votre enfance et la
pauvreté
qu'est ce que vous pensez du plan lancé
par le gouvernement de la mission qui a
été confiée à françois chérèque
qu'est ce que vous voulez si je critique
on va dire encore une être content de
rien en donner quelque chose de temps
mieux ils essayent de faire quelque
chose voilà
mais la racine de la pauvreté n'est pas
dans leçons à donner à la pauvreté la
racine de la pauvreté et dans le
dysfonctionnement général de l'économie
quand vous voyez kong où se propose
encore de réduire les indemnités de
chômage voire de les supprimer à
certains alors qu'il ya déjà la moitié
des chômeurs qui ne sont pas indemnisés
cela veut dire des conneries
et de gens dire notamment le délit est
du genre des milliers de gens vont être
précipitée dans le sens droit et dans la
pauvreté
voilà la racine sur les retraites
peut-être perrine puisque didier migaud
a dit qu'il vous le système et et
inégalitaire et qu'il y avait
certainement dans notre pays des
chômeurs qui était trop privilégié dans
le cadre d occuper de ces affaires parce
que dans ce pays a quand même une drôle
d'ambiance
maintenant voilà le conseil
constitutionnel qui décident de quel
niveau de l'impôt insupportable voilà
attendez je commence par le conseil d'un
conventionnel qui estime que 75% c'est
trop mais 68,5 c'est possible et puis
voici celui ci qui est président de la
cour des comptes qui se met n'ont pas
apporté des appréciations sur le bon
usage conforme à la décision politique
de la finance publique mais qui se met à
portée des appréciations en opportunités
et puis quoi encore c'est le
gouvernement des juges dans ce pays on
se manque à ce point de la
représentation parlementaire
on n'a aucune confiance dans la
démocratie sociale didier migaud doit
rester à sa place
il est là pour établir si les comptes
publics sont tenus de manière honnête et
sincère et conformément à la décision
publique et pas pour porté des
appréciations en opportunité
ça suffit maintenant les débordements de
pouvoir dans une cinquième république et
déjà à pyramidale d'une manière
absolument incroyable autour d'un seul
homme le président de la république où
pullulent les autorités indépendantes de
toute sorte
et voilà que les courses hors de leur
rôle pour faire de la politique ce n'est
pas acceptable car nous étions là leurs
questions sur le verdon qui est
pressenti pour prendre la tête de ads
elle a longé les mains pour prendre
cette fois c'est plutôt la bonne
nouvelle
ah bon oui parce que l'attitude du
gouvernement sur eads a été lamentable
la ds est le coeur de l'industrie
aéronautique française c'est nous les
français qui faisons le coeur de cette
affaire d'accord alors oublier cinq
minutes les allemands que un avis sur
tous les sujets mais les avions c'est
nous qui savons beauty pardon c'est une
nomination trop politique
et bien si ça ne leur plaît pas ils ont
qu'à s'en aller d'accord l'un ds est une
merveille technique c'est eux qui ont
tous vers le capital de eads 70% de
l'île capital flottant
les français seraient donc prêts pour
sacrifier à la lubie
d'idéologues libéraux devoir perdre
toute leur industrie aéronautique
alors madame lauvergeon me rassure parce
que moi la licence de l'opérateur une
bonne nouvelle pour les clients c'est
l'arrivée d'anne lauvergeon à la tête
sans doute de ads merci à vous c'est
elle qui commande c'est elle qui
commande c'est une femme et qui commande
dans la vie en général et notamment
répète que ses aspects merci encore
merci à tous a très vite
avez vous été agent secret ou
parachutiste nageurs de combat tireurs
d'élite pilote d'avion la voiture avait
reçu à droite la russie écharpes et
elles peuvent tous les bords sur la
place ici l'agent secret bob maloubier à
une vie digne d'un roman d'aventuré on a
fixé le vivier sur le fauteuil pour le
sapin lyonnais un documentaire portrait
qui permet de découvrir les coulisses
des services secrets de la république on
arrive et moi je me suis repassé à brest
alors à la brède par les égos l'espion
vous saluent bien
samedi à 22 heures sur public sénat
un éco village c'est un lieu de vie
c'est un lieu de partage et pour moi
c'est un lieu qui devrait se propager
pas mon partout
et s'il n'y avait rien du tout c'était
la forêt y avait juste un sentier de
petite randonnée ici qui faisait 60 cm
de large et puis on a commencé à
défricher à couper des arbres à couper
déjeuner à couper des herbes et puis
petit à petit on si on s'y est implanté
le dimanche il y avait souvent la
famille qui venait avec le grand-père la
grand mère les enfants tout ça pour
pourvoir les indiens si au début on nous
appelait comme ça dans la rue
s'installer dans la forêt vouloir vivre
à contre-courant forcément ça interroge
quand alexis lançons projets
d'écovillages il y a dix ans on a
d'abord cru à une secte il y a même eu
une enquête
ici les cinq maisons du hameau se fond
dans le paysage
aucune trace de béton tous les matériaux
sont naturels alexis a construit sa
maison lui même avec une idée si elle
doit disparaître
il ne doit en rester aucune trace ou
presque tout doit retourner à la terre
j'ai coupé les arbres
j'ai fait les planches avec une scie
mobile on a fait le statut ravec
et puis on a rempli en bottes de paille
la paille c'est l'isolant parce que
c'est un des meilleurs isolants et c'est
ça c'est de la paille de ces de la
paille de blé
on peut utiliser d'autres pays enfin moi
j'ai fait le choix de la paille de blé
et elle est dans les murs et dans le
plafond qui sait que la paille isole
parfaitement stockent la chaleur ou la
fraîcheur en fonction des saisons
écologique et surtout pas cher parce que
la paille c'est en déchets agricoles
contrairement au point il ya des essais
qui ont été faits en laboratoire sur la
paille et les bottes de paille ils sont
allés au lance flammes
il ya des tanks ont été calculés avant
justement que sa axa se désagrège
complètement et oumé saas conçues par
rapport à une maison conventionnelle en
part par une maison en paille mettra
beaucoup plus de temps à être détruites
par le feu
contrairement aux idées reçues les trois
petits cochons donc même si la paille
c'est pas très cher le coût de la maison
est quand même important que c'est plus
important que pour une maison
conventionnelle parce que ses pattes et
techniques qui sont encore très connu
c'est pas des techniques très connu mais
il ya quand même une grande partie des
matériaux qui sont qui peuvent rester
cher parce que c'est pas des matérieux
qui sont dans une très grande quantité
comme le le parpaing ou le ciment et
puis et puis il ya déjà beaucoup de main
d'oeuvre
donc cette main d'oeuvre aussi plus
revenir très cher depuis quatre ans
alexis construit sa maison un peu chaque
jour et elle n'est pas tout à fait
terminé encore une vie en chantier qui
se construit lentement
c'est vrai que quand je suis énervé un
peu stressé c'est vraiment très agréable
de venir passer un petit moment ici
d'une part pour regarder pour pour
apprécier pouvoir s'il n'y a pas de
graminées qui sont venus envahir parce
que ça les graminées je suis désolé mais
je leur laisse pas la place un jardin en
hauteur que tous les habitants cultivent
sur leur toit s'est inscrit dans la
charte du village on est parti sur
l'idée de dire si on rendait à la terre
la surface qu on lui prend donc de
mettre des plantes et des herbes et tout
ça sur la surface de la maison et puis
bon avantage des toits végétalisés c'est
des problèmes de condensation aussi ça
évite la condensation dans la maison
mais il a fallu s'accrocher pour que le
hic au hameau voit le jour des années de
luttes administratives qui ont fini par
en décourager certains
thomas et sa femme ont racheté le
terrain d'un couple qui a quitté le
projet eux aussi ont vécu en ville
eux aussi ont eu envie de rompre de fuir
une vie qu'il ne maîtrisait plus envie
d'autre chose pour eux et pour leurs
filles
on n'a pas vécu à les enfants ville on
arrivé là campagne avant heureusement
mais quand on y va on n'a pas les
réflexes dans un premier temps les à
face bad à côté de nous et puis on se
rend vite compte qu'ils ramassent des
mégots par terre qui amasse plein de
choses on se dit bon qu'est ce que je
fais
je lui interdis ce que je lui interdis
pas à la maison ça c'est compliqué et
alors qu'ici bon même si elles mêmes
tout noir plein de terre ou debout c'est
jamais bien grave l'habitat écolo permet
de dépenser moins
c'est ce qui est dans l'air du temps
mais pour thomas et mathilde ce n'est
pas ce qui compte c'est des gens qui se
tourne aujourd'hui vers l'éco
construction c'est